you are an amazing guy I mean I I
applaud you as in fact people always say
to me who are people that you think have
gone through adversity and risen and all
that you're one of those people to me I
don't even know how as a child that you
were able to concentrate on guitar and
play the guitar with your background you
know anything about Dave Navarro's
background I do not you you uh if I can
bring up some of your tragedies without
you without just turning into a Telethon
no absolutely your mother was killed
yeah at an early age by a guy who raised
you it was a guy who that she was dating
right and I wouldn't say he raised me I
think that that guy got lost in the
translation
no and truthfully truth be told he was
um you know I did trust the guy right I
was close to him right you know and why
not I mean you have two options uh I was
15. right 15 years old his mother was
taken away from him wow your parents
were divorced but it was a violent kind
of thing yeah your mom was murdered yeah
yeah and your mom was this beautiful
woman she was on The Price is Right I
mean she was doing well yeah she was she
was um it was actually my mother and my
aunt who happened to be there and and
they were murdered Yeah by this one guy
yeah and the guy got away with it for
like 10 years but the freaky thing is
that TV show because America's Most
Wanted got the guy yeah could you you
knew who did it oh yeah how did you know
he was the guy who killed your mom well
I kind of put two and two together I
mean I had a gun in my head a couple
weeks you know a week oh we did I didn't
know that yeah yeah so like there was a
point where um he had broken into the
house and held you know kind of held me
up and like handcuffed me and like
basically got pretty violent and then
let me go uh-huh who was this guy I mean
were they broken up at the time all this
was yeah he was so in love with her that
if he couldn't have her no one else
could I yeah I mean that's what you
would think I mean there's no logical
explanation for something like that yeah
but I mean I think in that irrational
thinking that's what was the guy's
locked up in prison now yeah have you
ever been able to say to this guy why'd
you take my mother from it
um no no no I mean because I don't I
don't think that any answer he could
give me to that yeah what could be
satisfied yeah it's going to be
satisfactory guitar save you like were
you like one of those kids who just like
sat in his room and played guitar when
all this happened I started at 11 so I
kind of had that as an Avenue all right
when you're that age or for me you don't
know where to go with that kind of stuff
no no and and you don't know who to talk
to you kind of don't even have the
dialogue to talk to anybody about that
kind of thing I mean it's just so
overwhelming right and so I just kind of
turned to music you know to me to come
back from something like that after your
mom was killed yeah your aunt I mean
just it's like your whole family and and
I guess your dad was do you have
brothers and sisters no no that's it
yeah no my dad was there he just you
know this you know he loved this woman
and so you know we were both kind of
like devastated yeah we were both
devastated and it was your whole life
uprooted in the sense also that you had
to move and yeah where'd you go well my
parents were divorced and I was living
with my mother right and um I ended up
just moving in with my dad I was in the
same city and and you know the weird
thing about it and like some a
connection I made years and years later
which was
um I used to spend Wednesday and
evenings with my dad right and for some
reason he couldn't see me one Wednesday
and he saw me on a Thursday instead
right and that's when this happened wow
and you could have been there and if I
was yeah and if that little chance
didn't happen I probably would have
gotten killed if you hadn't gone to
visit your father right so and I kind of
believe you know I mean and it's it's
unfortunate it's taken me years and you
know I had to create much more trauma in
order to get to this this place or
somehow you know I mean because you went
like and understandably you went like
crazy from this and I understand that uh
the drugs and all that kind of stuff
I'll tell you something about the drugs
and all that stuff and and I appreciate
you know you saying suggesting
understandably I went to that absolutely
at the same time though I I can confirm
that there was a part of me that used
that trauma as an excuse to pretty much
get away with whatever I wanted right so
you said oh yeah I'm allowed to do drugs
and whatever else you know for me I'm
you know I've had this you know this
horrible thing and like you can excuse
this you can excuse that and it it took
a lot of damage you know inflicted upon
myself yeah I'll say I mean I was
reading some of the stuff that I mean I
don't know where we got all this stuff
from maybe some of it's not true you
tell me okay let's clear it up all right
you know heroin addiction got so bad you
had sores on your face that exploded no
one would even go near you and stuff
yeah yeah I mean here you are you're
such a good looking guy and everything I
wonder how you know because the skin
looks perfect how do people come back
yeah how do you come like why do you not
have any scars on your face why are you
so lucky you know what I have no idea I
don't know I really don't and I do feel
totally blessed and lucky to be able to
come back from something like that yeah
and you know what and if anything else
it's like and I hate to sit here and
sound like arrogant and like I'm I've
got some message for anybody but the
truth of the matter is I was pretty bad
and and it's possible to come back if
you came back anybody could I hate to
say that because that you know that
implies that I'm as worse as bad as it
gets right but I was pretty bad and you
know and I've discovered that life is a
beautiful thing
foreign